las versiones encontradas reinan en el
conflicto en la región etíope del tigre
el frente de liberación nacional del
tigre considerado rebelde aseguró que
derribó un avión militar capturó al
piloto y retomó la ciudad de acción
cerca de la frontera con eritrea y
google estimó sus declaraciones se
producen sólo un día después de que el
primer ministro había ahmed anunciará el
control total de meckel en la capital
regional y el fin de la operación
militar que inició el pasado 4 de
noviembre entretanto la televisión
estatal informó que los rebeldes
escondían armas en una iglesia de adi
minso y los soldados federales
encontraron 70 fosas en la ciudad de
húmera airport 1 atacar cuando revisamos
el aeropuerto y el terreno en general
encontramos varias fosas expertas de los
alumnos sólo recientes y no algunas de
hace tiempo esto no es un cementerio la
pregunta es como propiedad pública se
convirtió en un cementerio
las comunicaciones en el tigre continúan
interrumpidas por lo que organizaciones
internacionales han asegurado que es
imposible establecer la situación real
para ver su gusto inglés de ayuda en la
agencia de naciones unidas para los
refugiados señaló que se necesitan 150
millones de dólares para ayudar a los
miles de etíopes que ha dejado el
conflicto
y hay alrededor de 44 mil refugiados que
han llegado en las últimas semanas y
aunque el ritmo ha bajado aún hay
cientos de personas que están cruzando
la frontera a diario detectar crossing
borders la organización resaltó que no
hay acceso a las comunidades vulnerables
dentro de etiopía e hizo un llamado al
gobierno para que permita la entrada de
ayuda humanitaria